I think we need to give her a chance
there's some of the things she stood on
he failed Chancellor she has totally
failed well look I know it's your job to
ask questions in those start terms but
what I would say to you is that she
takes a lot of decisions as prime
minister and one of the most difficult
aspects of being bad let me finish a
piece one of the most difficult aspects
of leadership is to be prepared to
change when you know things need to
change and she's done that and she
recognizes
and it's a very difficult thing to do
that some of those very big policies
were contributing to unanticipated
instability and therefore so I think we
need to respect that she's done that and
give her a chance I just want to ask
about something just to finish this off
she was warned about these policies and
the leadership race in fact where she
saw that he warned about all of these
things the former Chancellor and it came
to pass why is she still in the job well
I would rather a leader who listens
learns and changes and these are very
difficult times that's what we have with
this trust and I think we would have
more instability
much more instability if we went through
another long leadership process and what
I think homes want up and down the
country is certainty that's my job I
could ask you one more question about
this trust and we'll move on we should
be prime minister by Christmas I believe
so yes you think she will yes okay I
just want to quickly come on to spend
and I know I haven't got much time uh
defense budget three percent increase
election commitment of list crosses that
goes to go or not go well I'm going to
disappoint you Beth because I'm not
giving any answers on any specific
elements of spending or indeed on tax
because that's going to be decided but
what I am saying is two things yeah
first of all these are going to be very
difficult decisions and secondly we will
take all of them through the prism of
the inside on the most farm so so
defense budget Rising three percent
which is a commitment that she made to
become party leader you'll now say you
can't rule in or out pensions triple
lock for simply you're not rolling in
and out so I can I can make the process
shorter for you but I'm not ruining
anything in or else because
we have got a very difficult budgetary
situation I want to do what I can to
calm the markets I've been very open
about the changes we need to make but
I've also said in all areas of tax and
spend we're going to announce decisions
in two weeks time the reason I'm asking
you Chancellor and you'll know you'll
understand this is again this is a set
of policies that Liz truss announced in
order to be elected party leader and
prime minister and now you'll say that
you might have to reverse them just to
be clear you can't commit to any of them
not in the next two weeks but in two
weeks time you will know so the progress
we've been able to make and I think it's
important to say
um you know yes we've been open about
the things that needed to change and
indeed one or two mistakes but there is
a very challenging International
situation what's happening in Ukraine
what's happened to Global Energy prices
uh the impact of the pandemic and in the
face of all of those challenges
sometimes governments do need to change
direction I have a final question on
that number one you know the markets all
systems on this has been or the bank of
England has said something it was
self-inflicted there was a UK element to
some Market tunnel which presumably you
would acknowledge I want to remove that
UK element so that people know that
their mortgages if they do go up are
because of international considerations
just in terms of and I understand why in
terms of spending commitments you now
say you cannot rule anything in or else
at the moment until you've gone through
the forecast just final question how can
you be confident that you can get any of
these measures through cabinet or your
party
given that there are people in cabinets
such as the defense secretary for him
it's a red line
you might not be able to get these
through well um I may stand corrected
but I don't think there was a single
conservative MP I'm actually not sure
there was a single labor MP who opposed
the measures that I announced today in
Parliament so I think uh you know when
you look beneath the political rhetoric
actually there is widespread agreement
on the things that need to be done and I
hope that will be the case when I
announce the the fiscal statement in a
couple of weeks time just one more thing
generally hunt you stood for leader
twice some of your MPS are telling me
today that they would like you to be the
Prime Minister you have ruled that out
you rule that out completely you don't
want the job I rule it out Mrs hunt
rules it out three hunt children rule it
out and I think what they all think is
that I have a big enough task a big
enough Challenge and I want to focus on
doing that